oh my god
earwax is completely normal but it can
become troublesome and that's when you
might want to consider a procedure like
this one i'm katherine schuster bruce a
journalist and doctor working for
insider and i'm going to watch some
earwax removal videos
yeah i think that is quite a big
overreaction to how much pain or how
uncomfortable that actually is
ready
so you can see here they've got a
speculum
and that is something that they use to
keep the ear open so they can see the
earwax as best as possible so earwax is
completely normal and you should really
only be having a procedure to remove it
if it's causing you problems like
hearing loss earringing a funny
sensation in your ear if you're feeling
like the world is spinning or if it's
stopping things like you getting a
hearing aid fitted for example
[Music]
so the tool to remove the earwax depends
on where in the ear the earwax is
how hard it is or how soft it is and how
big it is
so here you have a hooked shape
instrument and that can be used to
scrape the ear wax off the ear canal a
bit like sticky toffee or fudge guide
so there's two types of earwax the oily
one which is softer and easier to get
out and the dry one which is harder if
you've got the hard type of earwax it
might be worthwhile using some olive oil
on your ear
to soften the wax and then come back for
the procedure
so this hoover-like device is the micro
suction and that is used to remove the
earwax
and you can use different tips on the
end so you can use a smaller one to
actually get the wax off the eardrum
so you're more likely to get earwax if
you're older or if you've got a small
ear canal but there's also things that
make it worse like using q-tips or
earbuds
this looks so crazy
oh oh sorry
as with any medical procedure there are
some risks to be aware of so if you're
getting this done you should stay still
and let the person doing it know if you
get any pain or changes in comfort
so ear wax is completely normal it
protects and it lines the ear canal
and it also has some mild antibacterial
properties because it's slightly acidic
so it's made from dead cells
some substances that come from the
glands in the air and also some dirt and
some dust
so the person doing this procedure
doesn't need to be a doctor but they
should have the relevant qualifications
so have a look before you get it done
having this procedure done does remove
the earwax but it can come back if you
continue to use things like q-tips